The principles of persuasion are
a set of psychological rules to
influence others. Originally there were
six: reciprocity, scarcity, authority,
consistency, liking, and consensus.
Later a 7th principle was added.
The first principle is reciprocity. It
means that if you give something to someone,
it makes them more open to being influenced
by you. This is because we don’t like to
feel that we owe someone and so we want to
return the favor to clear our social debt.
The second is scarcity. When people
perceive something as rare or limited,
they are more susceptible to persuasion. This is
driven by our desire to possess what others value,
and the fear of missing out that
prompts us to make decisions.
The third principle is authority. We
often trust powerful people and their
perceived expertise. We seek their guidance,
particularly in situations of uncertainty,
when we lack direction and need help from someone
else to make a difficult decision on our behalf.
Fourth is consistency. We are more likely
to do something if it's consistent with
past behavior. This is because we align our
actions with expectations. To influence someone,
ask for small commitments
first and larger ones later.
The fifth is liking. People are more willing
to say "yes" to those they are fond of. To
make people like you, find common interests,
be friendly, and give genuine compliments.
The sixth is consensus. Humans are inherently
social. They want to conform to the group.
Social proof can therefore persuade people
to commit to something, they otherwise doubt.
Psychologist Robert Cialdini, who came up with
the 6 rules, later added another one — unity.
Accordingly, people are more influenced by those
who share their beliefs, values, and experiences.
So do you think you understood
the principles? Then meet Jane,
a young entrepreneur who, after learning about
them, established a successful lemonade business.
Follow her story and try to tell us which
principles she uses and in what sequence.
To start her business, Jane first
needs to get funding. To do so,
she offers free samples to potential investors.
When she later presents her business idea,
those who tried her product are
now more likely to hear her out.
On her first week of business, Jane produces just
enough to satisfy some customers but
pretends to run out before everyone
gets what they lined up for. By doing
so, she creates a sense of exclusivity.
Jane then starts to showcase her top
customers, encourages positive reviews,
invites key opinion leaders to visit her shop,
and hosts a local band to play on Sundays.
Once her products are popular, customers can’t get
enough of them. To ensure she’s not losing anyone,
she distributes paper cups to those
in line. Those that take the cup,
are then more likely to
wait for what they came for.
Despite all that success, when Jane tries
to open a savings account, she gets laughed
at. So she partners up with her supplier, to
appear trustworthy enough to get the job done.
To strengthen her business, Jane listens to her
customers and shows interest in the community. As
a result, people will feel more connected to her
company and stay loyal despite the competition.
Now tell us in the comments below which of the
7 principles Jane applied and in what order!
Note that if these ideas aren’t
enough to get the job done,
here is one last piece of Cialdini’s advice:
“When we ask someone to do us a favor we will
be more successful if we provide a reason.
Even if the reason is utterly unreasonable.”
What do you think? Will knowing these rules
help you resist manipulation, and is it morally
acceptable to use them for personal gain?
Share your thoughts in the comments below!
This video was brought to you by shortform.com
ShortForm offers premium summaries of
nonfiction books. If you want to dig deeper,
say, on the principles of persuasion but
have no time, get ShortForm’s summary,
where you can highlight key
points, take personal notes,
share your favorite quotes and even
challenge your understanding with exercises.
The ShortForm library includes many
topics from the fields of education,
parenting and psychology — ShortForms’s
superpowered guides cover a new book’s key
ideas every week in simple language. Plus
it includes smart commentary and analysis.
Short Form is constantly adding
new features, such as Shortform AI,
a browser extension that summarizes everything
across the internet with a click of a button.
Shortform is a really an easy way to learn
about some of life’s most important ideas.
To get started, visit Shortform.com/sprouts
or click on the link in the description. You
will get a FREE trial of unlimited access
plus a 20% discounted annual subscription
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com